does the vatican acknowledge or see any
similarities between angelic
encounters and alien encounters
yes some people do yeah some people do
definitely i mean one of the uh former
directors of the observatory
uh definitely believed in um et's and
believed that et's
were
another kind of subset of god's creation
okay so that's another thing is that
a lot of people think like atheists or
people that i talk to like you know
people in congress or something like
that they're like
if we do if people
find out that ufos are real or something
it's gonna really you know
you know the religions are gonna crash
they're gonna implode and people are
gonna not believe in their religions
well that's not true at all because
people already who are religious have
categories for anomalous phenomena and
anomalous beings and non-human
intelligence so they already have these
categories in place that say atheists
don't have or some atheists just don't
have and so i think that that people who
are religious are going to be actually
very
in fact i think they already are they're
completely
okay with the idea that there are
perhaps
ets
or non-human entities not human
intelligent entities
because they already believe it
you know